waise kick the beat
take the please just hold on just a
second is that is that a genuine 1995
Furby yes
PewDiePie 2017 everyone that's not a
tripod hey Felix what's a what why did
you bring me here today
no you were here sorry I was already
here and so why have you called me in
today what are we doing Felix as a youth
super you'll live the high life no Pig
sorry let me take this as a YouTube but
today we're gonna find the ultimate
satisfaction I'm not talking about what
you think I'm talking about what do you
think I'm talking about a little bit of
satisfaction compilation videos they cut
through cut through items with the hot
knife oh yeah
playing with sand Machinery doing
symmetric work good today hmm
we're gonna live it kinetics and in real
life we get laughs brat God okay whoa
oh-ho
look at that I'll let you play with that
and it's one color as well my favorite
if only they're my favorite color
they'd provided more colors but instead
we just get something looks like
Bonnie's dick whoa sowhat's and it's
amazing also satisfied right now okay so
you don't use water as kinetic meaning
that when you when you mold it you are
you sense that's pretty
yeah that's pretty satisfying I think we
need to make something there
I also the more you move it the more it
gets harder you know gets harder feel it
do you want to get satisfied as well you
wanna make it hard
whoa that's what I'm saying right oh oh
this is Oh water not included because
what how are you not like into it I'm
into it
nothing like two grown men playing with
it with child sand I think this is just
hindering the experience you know yeah
no no no you got it do you think you can
eat it but my first thought was to put
in my mouth I don't know and well I
wonder what happens if you heat up a
thousand degree knife and cut it I
wonder
[Music]
what a knife cut through sand you're
surprised that a knife cut through sand
did it need to be hot to do that
how what level of satisfaction was that
for you science scientific uncharted
levels of satisfaction next Island next
item its Barney's dick again so I see
you've gone for the kind of the height
of a yeah yeah I think that's what they
like well I'm kind of going for the
girth you know do this is as beautiful
oh I will pray to that dude the
satisfaction you got to get in oh yeah
it kind of feels like Rice Krispies you
know when you put marshmallow and Rice
Krispies together kind of feels like
that a bit like a horrible creature that
you're fine in what's that show you like
Felix my little pony it's like it's like
you take a pony and you put it in a
blender and this is what comes out my
little knife I used to wonder what
friendship would be my lil never
[Music]
here we go cut it cut it
oh whoa that's actually pretty sad I
actually did feel pretty good I've never
actually done this before
Oh beautiful look at that look at that
oh oh oh Decapitator was that the head
or was that Brian you got it get in on
this brace is he really give it a while
give it a cut
[Music]
paper infused oh my god
a fuse together Oh Oh tables on fire
tape feel its tables on fire don't worry
about your tables are constant next item
[Music]
ah from the heavens we have been gifted
a child
no come on Felix jeez so suddenly give
him a chance to wrestle off a few lines
first mean I like it no he doesn't like
the fire really the ultimate
satisfaction
goodbye mr. family we're barely needed
hey music oh my god Felix right into the
antenna oh my God look at the smoke the
sadistic little bastard he's laughing
it's cutting slowly his eyes
then still you're making it so uh oh my
god his brain is melting oh my god he's
died did he die I don't know he's here
live no he's uh he's fine what a day
lalala I can't feel like the big WOW
will we started this we gotta finish it
yeah we have to cut through down the
middle that's just that's a fire night
oh my god feeling Jesus some compass I
want to see his ins I want to see his
exoskeleton I want to see I want to see
the made in China label that's it keep
going keep going through the oh he's
definitely dead now thing I inhaled some
plastic the black sludge was pouring out
of his brain [ __ ] me Oh what are you
doing Felix mr. football is not dead
Kill Confirmed my knife is on fire don't
worry about that cool
we should just um mr. star this is way
more real in the
No Jesus we can skin it
that's what yes we can sell that help to
the French smoke
[ __ ] him he doesn't die
Biggs [ __ ] she you were like a brother
to me
what are you doing you're like a father
to me hey why are you here look you
don't have to hide the body where are we
gonna hide it don't worry I got a plan
[Music]
we're gonna get kicked out that's right
god I thought you were responsible I'm
actually very disappointed in PJ I
expect their loss well I'm disappointed
in myself as well for not expecting this
to happen
get out have you ever tried the bungee
balancing everyday leave a like to this
video check out PJ's channel hey that's
what I like to hear and check out this
video
there are minds of this one except
they're flame dude this is great
exercise right can I try
[Music]